[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique une
fois encore nous parlons du mouvement
des gilet jaune mouvement commencé il y
a maintenant deux mois
aujourd'hui une question se pose comment
sortir de l'impasse
3 invité pour tenter de répondre à cette
question anne sophie pelletier de la
france insoumise
elle est candidate en position éligible
pour les européennes de mai pour le
parti de jean luc mélenchon
face à elle barbara beso balle aux
députés de la république en marche de
haute saône elle a été élue il ya 18
mois soit son premier mandat et puis
frédéric cros vice présidente du conseil
départemental du territoire de belfort
il est républicain il est également
conseiller municipal d'opposition à del
n'oubliez pas twitter avec le hashtag
dit mme paul fc comme dimanche en
politique franche comté vous pouvez
commenter cette émission les gilet jaune
on va justement les entendre tout de
suite dans un florilège de leurs
réactions recueillies lors des nombreux
reportages que nous avons consacré à ce
mouvement inédit
on nous ignore complètement les gens ils
en ont ras-le-bol de vie comme comme ils
sont en train de vivre qui vivent dans
la misère sociale ils peuvent plus vivre
diable d'argent en france et il faut la
partager ce pognon faut le partager via
le rétablissement de l'impôt sur la
fortune via l'augmentation des salaires
via l'augmentation des retraites il ya
une multitude de revendications pour que
le peut plus vivre décemment travaille à
l'hôpital chez john hay en tête j'ai
rejoint
le mouvement disent les jeunes depuis le
début parce que je vois les gens qui qui
sont en difficulté lerrick leurs
revendications va bien sûr en parler au
cours de cette émission on va commencer
tout de suite par un chiffre les gilets
jaunes sont à la une de l'actualité
depuis deux mois il y à des violences en
marge de leur manifestation des
conséquences graves sur le commerce
notamment
et pourtant 52% des français soutiennent
toujours ce mouvement alors anne sophie
pelletier
vous comprenez ce soutien encore au
majoritaire dans le pays mais qui s'est
effritée quand même
il était à 65 % il ya encore un mois
bien sûr que je comprends ce soutien
majoritaire puisque de toute façon on a
vu à longtemps et fréquemment sur toutes
les chaînes d'information les violences
knees mise en exergue que je dirais on a
parlé de violence de violence de
violence de violence dg des jaunes qui
s'effrite jeu que le soutien s'effrite
personnellement j'en suis pas si sûr que
ça et chauffe quand même que 52% des
français après deux mois où comme je le
dis les violences ont été plus que
montrer et on n'a pas forcément non plus
écouté que les revendications du gilet
jaune
c'est encore un large soutien à la
mobilisation frédéric crous vous en
pensez quoi vous de ce soutien encore
majoritaire je crois que les français
attendent des réponses aujourd'hui il ya
les gilet jaune mais il ya eu six
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens qui
attendent maintenant des réponses
concrètes
d'abord au matraquage fiscal comme on
disait
et puis il n'ya pas que le matraquage
fiscal il ya aussi l'ensemble des normes
il ya il ya un pays qui va mal il ya du
chômage il ya des petites retraites
il ya des commerçants qui ont du mal à
s'en sortir des artisans il ya aussi des
salariés
voilà je pense on aurait tant développés
à tour ses avait réponse concrète à à
ces problèmes alors il y a environ une
cinquantaine de députés de la république
en marche qui ont été agressés menacés
dont par exemple christophe lejeune le
l'autre député de haute-saône votre
collègue de la république en marche
est ce que vous vous avez eu peur est ce
que c'est par peur
or que vous n'êtes pas allé sur les
barrages on a reçu une question de
bertrand bertrand qui vous dit madame
vous êtes élu par certains gilet jaune
du rond-point de noidans les vesoul
c'est le grand centre donc des gilet
jaune ces dernières semaines
pourquoi n'êtes vous pas venu les
rencontrer sur le terrain je suis
surprise que cette personne me dise
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas venus nous
rencontrer les rencontres j'essaie de
les multiplier je passe si je ne suis
pas à paris je passe à être le montant
être sur le terrain à aller à la
rencontre
alors effectivement pas forcément des
gels et jaune mais aussi aller à la
rencontre mais déjà dès que vous les
avez vus depuis deux mois bien sûr j'ai
rencontré j'ai rencontré toute une
équipe là-bas de vesoul qui était
effectivement enfin mener l'équipe
n'était pas mené mais elle était
chapeautée par céline roy ont qui était
le contact principal il ya huit
personnes qui sont venues à la
permanence on a passé deux heures et
demi ensemble
donc vous pensez que bell rendant se
trompe alors quand il vous dit vous les
avez pas rencontré à alors j'ai
rencontré les jets les jaunes
effectivement je ne suis pas allé sur le
rond-point de noix dans ce que vous avez
j'ai rencontré cinq groupes non en si la
peur nous gagne c'est le néant derrière
on n'a pas à avoir peur de quoi que ce
soit il faut faire attention de ne pas
tomber dans la peur le jour où on tombe
dans la peur ça peut être dévastateur et
derrière on se résigne donc il est hors
de question construisent unis alors anne
sophie pelletier je pense que c'est le
mam bertrand qui vous posent également
une question pour vous alors vous êtes
comme je disais candidat de la france a
soumis aux européennes
alors votre visage n'est pas inconnu
puisque vous avez mené la grève à
l'ehpad de foucherans dans le dans le
jura n'est pas tout seul
vous étiez à la tête de cette grève et
vous allez publier un livre dans
quelques jours lors bertrand dit
pourquoi jean luc mélenchon ne se
désolidarise style pas clairement des
gilet jaune violent alors je vais
m'adresser à bertrand je vais lui dire
que jean luc mélenchon n'a jamais appelé
à la violence il faut encore regarder
les vidéos qui l'a fait récemment la
france a soumis c'est jean luc mélenchon
en particulier nous sommes hostiles à la
violence et à toute forme de violence
donc il n'ya pas de solidarité avec des
gens qui pourrait être violente de notre
côté ce n'est pas ce n'est pas tout à
fait exact
et puis par contre nous ce que nous
disons à la france a soumise c'est que
la violence ne sert pas un mouvement
c'est évident mais nous appelons à ce
qui est grand nombre de personne puisque
nombre fera force pour faire plier
pour nous ce gouvernement et je voudrais
quand même revenir sur quelque chose qui
est intéressant puisque hier il ya eu
donc un acte 9 et dance et techno 9
on voit bien quand même que les
violences ont diminué et j'en appelle
jean fait état aussi parce que jean luc
mélenchon avait avait été clairement
dans ses vidéos que les jets les gens ne
pouvaient aussi aller avec des casques
blancs et qui ferait aussi un peu le
servir le service d'ordre
c'est dans ce cas s'est passé je vous
presse un petit peu parce qu'il ya plein
plein de choses sur lesquelles on
aimerait vous entende
alors comment sortir de l'impasse et
justement le titre de l'émission
peut-être en débattant c'est ce que
propose le président de la république et
le gouvernement
en attendant ce grand débat national un
tour de chauffe si j'ose dire a eu lieu
à l'initiative de l'association des
maires ruraux de france la haute saône
est deux seuls départements de
franche-comté à y avoir participé
cahiers de doléances propositions près
d'une centaine de communes ya répondu
on écoute le président de la rmr de ce
département jean paul carteret les gens
ils ont besoin de parler de s'exprimer
d'échanger sur sur plein de sujets
tellement longtemps qu'on ne les a pas
considéré au moins un petit peu et c'est
justement là la sonnette d'alarmé que
les maires ruraux thirion depuis si
longtemps
donc aujourd'hui que les nos concitoyens
puissent s'exprimer au plus près le pré
2 c'est le sens de la démocratie locale
ce qui revient c'est la justice sociale
la justice fiscale la transition
écologique et énergétique l'organisation
politique et territorial le rôle de
l'état dans les territoires
le rôle de l'état dans les territoires
la proximité c'est les services
c'est ce qu'on dénonce depuis longtemps
l'aménagement le transport et les
mobilités
[Musique]
donc on a commencé donc à débattre en
haute saône frédéric roux c'est ce que
vous pensez que c'est le rôle des maires
de lancer ce débat
écoutez je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller municipal d'opposition à del
oui les maires les élus locaux il est
temps qu'on les écoute et il est temps
que je dirais les communes ont perdu moi
je vois dans ma commune adèle c-434 1000
euros de dotations de l'état qui ont été
perdus depuis 2014
le département du territoire de belfort
à perdre et si vous alliez en europe il
est temps qu'on écoute enfin si les élus
le maire en tant qu'élus locaux au
relais du gouvernement vous risquent
aussi de vous retrouver dans une
position un peu en adéquation pas le
relais du gouvernement
simplement il est temps qu'on entende
les gens et surtout de parole des gilet
jaune
non non moi je suis pas échoir taille je
suis porte parole j'entends la colère il
et nous nous pouvons entendre un certain
nombre de choses je veux dire les
raisonnements moi je suis élu local
depuis trois ans j'entends je connais
les attentes de ces personnes j'ai reçu
encore hier une maman dans ma permanence
qui a deux enfants à charge et qui a un
petit salaire et qui ne s'en sort pas
voilà et quelle réponse on apporte à ça
moi je pense qu'il est temps qu'on
écoute les gens qu'on écoute les élus
locaux les collectivités locales
notamment ont été complètement dézinguer
pendant plusieurs années maintenant je
pense qu'il est temps qu'on fasse de la
proximité
les grands débats c'est formidable je
n'ai justement peut-être que des
français ne pensent pas que le grand
débat c'est vraiment formidable puisque
quelques chiffres pour présenter ce
débat toujours selon les sondages
donc c'est bien sûr à prendre avec des
pincettes mais pour le moment avant
qu'il commence on n'a que ça à se mettre
sous la dent si j'ose dire
le grand débat national seulement 34%
des français veulent type participer
donc à 1 sur 3 seulement et d'autres
chiffres encore 70% considèrent que ce
débat n'est pas indépendant 80% qu'il
n'aborde pas tous les sujets 70% qu'il
n'en ressortira aucune mesure utile
barbara baisse au balo ça commence mal à
mes scemama encore commencé c'est déjà
mal engagée
et effectivement et
et ça s'appelle de pessimisme et on a
besoin d'optimisme pour pouvoir
construire ensemble les doléances les
doléances
c'est une bonne chose on doit dire là où
on a mal d'accord ensuite et vous savez
quand on va visiter effectivement
l'ehpad où je suis allé lors de la
sécheresse quand on va visiter le centre
de police départementale lorsqu'on va
visiter la gendarmerie lorsqu'on va
visiter la maison d'arrêt lorsqu'on va
visiter tous ses services
à chaque fois que j'en suis ressorti en
tout cas je me suis dit non seulement il
ya du travail mais comment on va faire
pour redresser tout ça comment et là on
est en pleine de nouer justice donc
c'est vraiment des domaines
effectivement qu'il faut regarder d'un
peu plus près les hôpitaux c'est la même
chose et c'est comment faire pour
construire on doit on d'oise passé dans
l'étape le moment on est tous d'accord
sur le fait que les choses vont mal ah
oui elles vont mal ce sont les doléances
on écoute bien effectivement là où ça va
mal maintenant qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
construire bâtir
quelles vont être les nouveaux les
nouvelles parties à construire pour
vraiment va demander donc vous vous y
croyez la roue un ce grand débat
national moi le grand débat il est mort
né voilà tout ce que c'est l'état qui
choisit les questions les thèmes
donc il est peut-être aussi amené à
choisir les réponses et je voudrais
revenir sur deux choses monsieur route
vous dit qu'il est temps que les
communes et les collectivités sont
entendus que les maires soient entendus
on sera d'accord là dessus et vous dites
je ne suis pas le porte parole des gilet
jaune mais l'organisation et on entend
bien ces mères sont là pour en faire
remonter les doléances des déchets des
jaunes donc pour vous cette organisation
va permettre simplement que l'économie
soit entendu c'est pas vraiment de ce
que j'en ai compris la vallée des choses
on va laisser une deuxième chance madame
baisse au balo vous dites vous dise
clairement vous êtes allés visiter un
ehpad vous êtes allés visiter tout ça je
suis ravi de vous l'ayez fait mais vous
dites comment construire je pense que
déjà il faudrait pas que votre
gouvernement
déconstruisent nos services plus qu'à
faire ça c'est votre avis ensuite même
perçu à mon avis madame des sceaux
baloutches qui s'est laissée là
répondait après on donnera la réponse
valérie sur le gouvernement actuel qui
déconstruit pour moi il ne déconstruit
pas ensuite lorsque vous dites
le grand débat effectivement c'est perdu
d'avancé d'accord c'est votre avis
qu'est ce que vous proposez à la place
vous proposez quoi à la place du grand
débat pour pouvoir analyser comprendre
et proposer derrière le cahier des
doléances j'aimerais préciser
effectivement le cahier des doléances et
de propositions jamais on le dit on
parle du cahier des doléances et de
propositions en tout cas j'en ai regardé
quelques-uns a effectivement je remercie
jean paul carteret d'avoir remis ça en
place maintenant à l'association des
maires de haute saône
oui a été très réactif c'est
effectivement très bien ce cahier de
doléances et deux propositions
maintenant je suis plus dubitatif sur
qu'allons nous en faire parce que attend
dé me wade c'est une réponse bien
gervasi vous avez un c'est embêtant mais
c'est pas un grand débat d'hier j'ai mal
quelque part c'est une chose
maintenant dire comment on fait et
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour l'avenir c'est
autre chose
il ya beaucoup moins de monde autour de
la table donc moi je demande
effectivement que le grand débat
national
c'est ça l'objectif du grand débat c'est
de dire on se met autour de la table on
voit ensemble
et qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
ensemble qu'est ce qu'on fait ensemble
attend dé moi je pense qu'il faut pas se
tromper de débat dans cette histoire le
le cahier de doléances pourquoi pas il y
en a un dans ma commune il ya inquiète
doléances à belfort il y a enfin très
honnêtement le grand débat pourquoi pas
je veux dire les on peut on peut tous
parlé cette importante qu on entendre
simplement les le diagnostic on le
connaît maintenant il faut qu'on apporte
des solutions concrètes
on a envie pardonnez-moi mais emmanuel
macron a infligé depuis le début de son
mandat plus de quatre milliards d'impôts
et de taxes supplémentaires
je veux dire arrêtons ce matraquage
fiscal
apprenons à gérer les choses autrement
arrêtons 25 agents des collectivités g
faisons confiance aussi aux élus locaux
moi je vous savez que par les deux
relais tout à l'heure moi je suis un élu
local je sers mes concitoyens et je les
entends tous les jours j'ai pas besoin
les gilet jaune n'est que l'expression
finalement
un ras-le-bol parce qu'à un moment donné
depuis paris les gens à une question des
mille questions sont plus entendus il ya
une question de antoine et mélusine qui
se rejoint qu'il dise quels sont
justement les garanties que vous
apportez pour ce grand débat national
puisque vous avez fixé un cap vous dites
on appellera de parler de la peine de
mort lives et gilles mariage pour tous
on n'a pas le droit de remettre en cause
la politique du gouvernement depuis 18
mois alors qu'est ce qu'il reste comme
marge de manoeuvre et s'il sort des
choses très concrètes
est ce que vous allez les appliquer
transition écologique démocratie
citoyenneté fiscalité organisation de
l'état et services publics
voilà c'est la dhr de la discussion si
nous donnons pas de cadre de disques oui
je veux donner un cadre il faut donner
un cadre effectivement il ya certaines
parties ce sont des cons des combats
sociaux comme par exemple la peine de
mort ça a été ré écouter ce qu'elle peut
dire badinter écouter ce qu'a pu dire
simone veil par rapport il va revenir
là-dessus non confirmée par exemple il
ya une news une autre question de fanny
et gilles pourquoi ne pas rétablir
griefs
est-ce que c'est pas maintenant lire une
erreur une erreur de dire d'entrée de
jeu on va pas rétablir les seuls en tout
cas les sf l'impôt de solidarité sur la
proposition déjà ce n'est pas la
disparition de liesse puisqu'il était
remplacé par l'ifi donc tout ce qui est
immobile ye est toujours taxer une grand
patrimoine on va dire souvenez vous je
les ai vus il ya pas très longtemps
justement la télévision souvenez-vous de
gainsbourg quand il brûle son billet de
500 euros parce qu'il est taxé à 75% ça
s'enfonce en tête ça c'est 1 500 forum
lardons saas en france était déjà
beaucoup d'argent c'était déjà
énormément d'argent à l'époque en tout
cas mode et de ses billets là à l'époque
que je ne vais jamais eu dans ma poche
alors il était temps que ça soit 104
qu'est ce qu'ils pensaient les sf a été
en place pendant des décennies ça
n'allait pas mieux à la fin d'heuliez
nsm et services un peu vous avez compris
que c'était un symbole presque moi j'ai
lu les cahiers de doléances quelque part
position de haute saône c'est revient
régulièrement si tu fais ça revient
régulièrement effectivement c'est un peu
plus de 3 milliards effectivement un
quinquennat ces cinq ans est très très
court ou plus d'un an et demi on nous
fait la peau entre guillemets parce que
nous on nous afflige effectivement de
tous les maux qui ont été accumulées
pendant des décennies au bout d'un an et
demi on nous demande un petit peu ça me
fait le même effet que
on pourrait avoir un enfant et on lui
demanderait d'avoir le bac au bout de
six mois il faut combien de temps il
faut pour éduquer élever un enfant
combien de temps il faut une grossesse
ça dure toujours pour faire un enfant ça
dure toujours neuf mois enfin il semble
après nous avouera jamais reid et là on
nous demande en 18 mois de tout
transformer alors que nous sommes en
transformation encore une fois nous
sommes en paix ni la justice
on n'en parle pas du tout de la loi
justice pourquoi pourquoi on parle pas
du tout cette loi là c'est pas dans
l'erreur
il questionne d'aidé gilet jaune yves
alors non les dans l'immédiat on parle
beaucoup du gilet jaune et il faut qu'on
en parle
bien entendu c'est un sujet mais c'est
un sujet aussi la réforme de la justice
c'est un sujet aussi les réformes de la
retraite qui arrive c'est un sujet aussi
les réformes de temps en temps en même
temps edouard philippe a dit qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de réformes qui
allaient attendre justement le résultat
du grand débat se soit l'organisation
territoriale la loi d'orientation et la
réforme constitutionnelle
justement donc à leur écoute non il a
dit on va attendre
je ne dis pas que c'est d'écouter
montchanin qui à bout référé voilà
entendre et on s'étend vers allard ya
une demande très forte et marie est
l'une des téléspectateurs ou des
téléspectatrices qui nous a demandé de
relayer cette question est ce que vous
êtes favorable au rhic au référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
on va commencer par frédéric rousseau ce
référendum pour ou contre
écoutez pour contredire oui il faut
entendre les gens je sais pas si je suis
convaincu que le référendum
simplement je dis ce qu'il faut associer
davantage les gens vous savez pourquoi
on relance tous ces débats aujourd'hui
sur le référendum c'est tout simplement
parce que l'état est tellement
déconnectés des réalités et que à un
moment donné les les gens ont besoin
d'être entendus
je veux dire qu'on fasse aussi confiant
je le répète aux collectivités locales
je dis ça parce qu'il faut qu'on lance
surtout un nouveau programme un nouveau
plan de décentralisation
c'est très important il faut que l'état
se reconcentre sur ses compétences
légales que tout allait nous à part y
compris les tenants les technos et mike
fisher et ça c'est déjà un peu dans le
sollicita riches et non c'est pas
populiste est pas un cliché simplement
moi ce que je dis aujourd'hui pourquoi
on lance tous eric maintenant alors on a
un nouveau terme à la mode c'est le
rique moi je vais vous dire dans nos
collectivités les communes
les deux départements nous entendons
aussi nous nous associons nos
concitoyens quand nous faisons un projet
par exemple nous leur demandons leur
avis et on est capable aussi de deux pas
de retirer un projet quand il est pas
bon et de laisser camp nou concitoyens
nous disent que je suis est aussi
directeur de cabinet de damien meslot le
maire de raifort et il a retiré
j'ai interrogé important l'année
dernière bien sûr sur les berges sur les
berges de la savoureuse
damien meslot avait entendu justement
les concitoyens qui n'était pas
favorable à ce projet il a entendu ses
concitoyens à retirer le projet va
demander que les tirs à un moment donné
entendent la réalité du terrain et c'est
ça qui est important et sérieux comme la
percée pas avec vous tout simplement
et puis pourquoi pas reprendre l'exemple
de la suisse qui fait des votations nous
sommes frontaliers moi je suis un élu
frontaliers la suisse fait des votations
sur un certain nombre de sujets qui
intéressent les optionnel et les suces
et bien eu les tendons ces votations
pourquoi pas verlan d'air la dame
pelletier l'oryx est une revendication
de la france insoumise loric est une
revendication alors le rique je vous ai
pas besoin d'homme d'initiative
citoyenne je trouve ça quand même plus
joli
oui c'est une revendication de la france
est soumise depuis
depuis l'avenir en commun c'est quelque
chose que nous que nous voulons et c'est
arrivé comme ça chili gilet jaune à
moment donné en a mais vous savez je
vous faire une confidence il y à il ya
des insoumis partout et même sur les
ronds-points donc non c'est pas vrai si
si je vous assure donc bien que si le
risque le risque nous y sommes
favorables et je voudrais vous dire sur
quelque chose madame beso ballot que
vous avez dit vous êtes depuis 18 mois
aux manettes mais monsieur macron ça
fait pas dix huit mois qu'il est dans la
politique je veux dire il était déjà
sous monsieur hollande il a déjà pris
des décisions
donc vous pouvez pas nous sortir
l'argument que votre vous n'êtes pas des
lapins de six semaines quoi vous vous
c'est votre premier mandat mais monsieur
macron reconnaissaient déjà l'état des
choses et a pris déjà des mesures
concernant notre pays puisqu'il était
sous le gouvernement hollande n'est ce
pas oui il était saoul gouvernement
effectivement donc il s'amenait seul
connaît très bien la souris laisser
enfermer un répit mais les français
connaissaient très bien la situation
aussi il y a eu un vote
effectivement les résultats du vote on
était là on doit revoir je suis d'accord
aussi quand vous dites l'état paraît
complètement déconnecté mai
on peut l'entendre ça et c'est pour ça
qu'on doit remettre à plat et de revoir
effectivement comment on organise les
choses comme on réorganise les choses la
défiance par rapport à vous préparer
pour les élections européennes
je vous souhaite d'être élu que le
meilleur gagne j'allais dire je vous
souhaite d'être élu pour voir aussi
comment ça se passe parce que vous allez
voir
une fois que vous êtes amateurs tous
ceux qui ont été élus effectivement
insoumis ou ou à lille il arrive
effectivement avec tout un tas de
d'espoir et après il faut faire avec
tout le monde il faut que s'ils avaient
atteint soumis à l'assemblée nationale
il n'y arrive pas je n'y arrive pas ne
sont pas dans leur rôle
enfin je sais pas je vois pas où vous
voulez en venir là je vous souhaite bien
sûr que les 17 députés a soumis sont
toujours dans leur conviction et j'y
arrive
ils sont puisqu'il ya encore un projet
de loi qui a été dépouillé alors à
savoir mieux de mise sur le ré et alors
ça va mieux
écoutez nous on se bat et alors ça va
prendre combien on ne le voit pas comme
comme mais on se bat mais on se bat tous
on se bat tous dans l'intérêt général
on a tous ces mots là la bougie too soon
et moi maintenant encore une fois je
vous dis simplement par rapport au grand
débat national puisque c'est ça le point
central de ce matin qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ensemble pour aller ensemble vers du
mieux pour aller ensemble effectivement
à payer moins d'impôts avoir un service
public qui est même plus efficient
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais on connaît
cela d'abord connectez vous avec les
acteurs locaux aussi les élus locaux les
syndicats les associations si vous
voulez vous dire encore une fois il a
aussi en 18 c'est ce compte en mai et
puis apprenez à mieux gérer l'état avant
d'augmenter comment nous faisons nous
dans nos collectivités
au lieu d'augmenter nous n'avons jamais
augmenter les impôts dans notre
collectivité départementale
depuis que nous sommes aux manettes les
tables au lieu d'augmenter les impôts et
bien ferait mieux d'apprendre à gérer un
peu les choses autrement
il ya 20 milliards d'euros d'économies
qu'on peut faire sur la gestion même de
l'état je veux dire c'est impressionnant
il n'y a aucune piste ce qui est annoncé
là dessus on peut faire des économies
drastiques on peut faire des économies
sur les normes aussi gêna solution
l'ensemble de ce qu'ils aient
l'impression vous entendant madame b ce
ballot que vous aussi vous vous avez
vous êtes heurté à un principe de
réalité en entrant l'assemblée nationale
mais tout ce qui est dénoncée en ce
moment c'est ce qu'ont dénoncé
auparavant
c'est ce qu'ont dénoncé ce qu on a
dénoncé moi je vais mettre un gilet
jaune quoi mais dans le départ du gilet
jaune aujourd'hui métrages et les autres
ce serait vraiment compliqué pour moi
quand même
mais les revendications qui ont été
faites par les gilet jaune au départ du
mouvement
j'ai la sensation que c'est exactement
ce que j'ai défendue au moment de ma
campagne donc qu frédéric rose par les
collectivités locales qui ne sont plus
des relais de l'état etc
vous vous dites aussi qu'en tant que
député vous aimeriez plus exister à
l'assemblée nationale et plus exister
vis-à-vis du
gouvernement et du président mais plus
c'est qu'on a tous envie de plus exister
il faut avoir la meilleure des balances
pour à la fois plus exister à la fois
être mieux entendues et à la fin on peut
pas faire avec les humeurs de chacun
parce qu'on va pas s'en sortir il faut
aussi prendre une décision tranchée et y
aller un moment donné
peut-être qu'on a trop tranche peut-être
que le gouvernement a tranché un mandat
ni trop tranchées sans nous écoutez je
pense quand je vous dis ça je pense
particulièrement par exemple aux 80 km à
peut-être qu'on appelle qu'on n'est pas
assez en tout mais souvenons nous aussi
que l'on venait d'une période on avait
peut-être tendance à écouter ça a été
reproché de d'écouter aussi trop les uns
les autres
la sncf par exemple y avait trois cent
vingt mille personnes dans la rue aupicq
effectivement de du plus haut de des
manifestations dans les rues par rapport
à la réforme de la sncf nous sommes
arrivés à combien depuis combien de
temps on en parlait depuis combien temps
alors effectivement la violence qui est
émise par rapport au gilet jaune fait
que ça ça a bouleversé et basculer
toutefois personne jusqu'à tampon pour
conclure quand même parce qu'il reste
deux minutes laurent wauquiez ces deux
grands perdants politique de ce
mouvement d gilet jaune parce qu'on l'a
pas vu pas entendu il a mis un gilet
jaune il a enlevé tout mais enfin les
républicains ont du mal d'exister un peu
du tout enfin je suis pardonnez moi je
suis élu républicain vous l'avez dit
j'existe je suis un élu local qui agit
lorsque a fait une fois des propositions
très claires avec un big bang fiscal
notamment et 20 milliards d'euros
d'économies sur le train de vie de
l'état
je trouve que ce sont des propositions
intéressantes il a fait des propositions
sur la suppression des normes
il a fait des propositions sur
l'apprentissage parce qu'il est
peut-être temps qu'on parle
d'apprentissage aussi il est temps qu'on
parle d'emploi il est temps qu'on parle
également on va donner la parole à
madame pelletier la france insoumise
donc aux européennes est ce que vous
avez peur d'une concurrence d'une liste
gilet jaune
mais pourquoi aurions nous peur d'une
concurrence nous sommes pas là pour nous
sommes pas sur les ronds-points et en
soutien du mouvement des filets jaunes
pour prendre des parts de marché
s'il ya des gens qui ont les mêmes
propositions est qui et qui veulent
monter une vigile et jaune d'abord qui
serions nous pour leur interdire et
deuxièmement je me posais un peu la
question mais est ce que cette 7 things
liste gilet jaune venez aux européennes
est ce que ça ne servirait pas un peu le
gouvernement friands vous pouvez
répondre à cette question il vous reste
40 secondes
c'est une question oui c'est une
question et je le prends plutôt comme
une commune remarques ou le bouton bien
cette tutelle n'ont pas gênant je n'irai
pas jusque là j'ai quand même un peu
plus de bienveillance et de respect
c'est une analyse c'est une manière de
voir ok c'est un constat c'est comment
comment analyser sa commande
oui c'est à cause est ce que ça va
profiter aux gouvernements l'avenir nous
le dira l'avenir nous le dira on verra
bien comment ça se passe en tout cas
aujourd'hui les choses sont telles
qu'elles sont et il faut que nous
avancions surtout ce sera le mot de la
fin je suis désolé donc le temps des
missions et et est terminé merci
mesdames merci monsieur d'y avoir
participé
merci de votre attention et surtout bon
dimanche après midi à tous au revoir au
revoir
[Musique]